just a few weeks on from the Philip
Schofield Scandal Here We Go Again
headlines dominated with claims of
questionable professional conduct by
another well-known British TV presenter
this time at the BBC a celebrity is said
to be on a six-figure salary who for now
remains Anonymous facing claims he paid
a 17 year old for sexual photos not
merely sleazy in theory Criminal
the teenager's mother told the son she
blamed the BBC man for giving money to
fuel her child's drug addiction she
claimed one time he sent five thousand
pounds the money had been in exchange
for sexually explicit photographs of my
child telling the newspaper I liked
seeing him on TV until my child showed
me a snap of him on the sofa in his
underwear suspended now but questions
over why the BBC did not take the
presenter off air immediately now in
contact with the police the BBC except
they first became aware of a complaint
in May new allegations were put to us on
Thursday of a different nature and in
addition to our own inquiries we have
also been in touch with external
authorities in line with our protocols
it does call into question the the uh
the ethics the investigations how long
these things take and the BBC but also
other broadcasters do need to get a grip
of course conversations about
safeguarding procedures are commonplace
at most workplaces nowadays but as our
public service broadcaster in receipt of
Public Funding arguably the BBC is held
to a higher standard and don't forget
inside here they're all too aware of the
need for transparency right now
following the resignation of former
chairman Richard Sharp over the Boris
Johnson loan Scandal so being seen to
drag their heels on this one giving the
impression of prioritizing protecting
Talent rather than quickly acting to
investigate what was going on well not
only is it not a good look but it speaks
volumes about the repeated failings of
management here when it comes to being
seen to be on the ball honest and open
hi guys quickly are you pleased with the
response to the BBC if you
have you had the answers you want
culture secretary Lucy Fraser has spoken
to the head of the BBC about the claims
but at Silverstone was tight-lipped
about the content of those discussions
is there investigation continues the BBC
has promised further updates in the
coming days
looks as though we're reaching a point
where inevitably the name will come out
because given the evidence that we we
understand that it's now available then
it seems extremely likely that the
police will arrest and interview this
person and then in due course it looks
likely that they'll be charged
that the presenter in question remains
Anonymous is arguably convenient for the
BBC but with many asking why the star in
question is being afforded such
privilege and protection there's
mounting pressure on the corporation to
explain what they knew and when Katie
Spencer Sky News